HIGH-PROFILE BRIEFINGS BEGIN ON
THE
THE HILL END OF THE WHITE HOUSE,
THERE WAS NO IMMEDIATE RESPONSE
FROM McCABE'S LAWYER OR THE
BUREAU, BRET.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN ANOTHER TRAGIC WEEK
FOR U.S. MILITARY AVIATION.
FIVE SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE DIED
AND THE ACCIDENTS ARE
CONTINUING.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN IS AT THE
PENTAGON WITH THE FALLOUT.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
LATE TODAY, THE AIR FORCE
IDENTIFIED THE PILOT KILLED IN
YESTERDAY'S F-16 COAT, CRASHED
OUTSIDE LAS VEGAS.
HE FLEW FOR THE ELITE
THUNDERBIRDS, HAD MORE THAN 3500
FLYING HOURS AND 30
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLANES.
HE WAS VERY EXPERIENCED, YET HAS
SPIDERED JET CRASHED DURING A
ROUTINE TRAINING FLIGHT.
IT MARKS THE THIRD CRASH FOR THE
THUNDERBIRDS IN LESS THAN TWO
YEARS, AND THE THIRD MILITARY
AIRCRAFT TO CRASH IN THE PAST
TWO DAYS.
ON TUESDAY, A MARINE CORE SUPER
STALLION HELICOPTER CRASHED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, KILLING
FOUR MARINES.
EARLIER THAT DAY, IN THE EAST
AFRICAN NATION OF DJIBOUTI, A
MARINE CARRIER JET CRASHED ON
TAKEOFF.
THE PILOT EJECTED AND WAS
RELEASED FROM THE HOSPITAL BUT
TODAY, THE DJIBOUTI GOVERNMENT
GROUNDED ALL U.S. MILITARY
FLIGHTS INCLUDING DRONES FROM
THE LARGEST AMERICAN BASE IN
AFRICA, HINDERING
COUNTERTERRORISM OPERATIONS.
THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE NONCOMBAT
AVIATION CRASHES THIS YEAR
ALONE, KILLING NINE
SERVICE MEMBERS.
37 WERE KILLED IN AIR CRASHES
LAST YEAR.
NEARLY DOUBLE THE NUMBER KILLED
IN 2016.
BUT A TOP GENERAL AT THE
PENTAGON WOULD NOT CALL IT A
CRISIS.
>> I WOULD REJECT IT'S A CRISIS.
THOSE ARE MISHAPS THAT OCCURRED.
WE WILL LOOK AT EACH ONE IN
TURN.
EACH ONE IS TRAGIC.
WE REGRET EACH ONE.
WE WILL LOOK AT THEM CAREFULLY.
I'M NOT PREPARED TO SAY IT'S A
WAVE OF MISHAPS OR SOME FORM OF
CRISIS.
>> THE HOUSE ARMED SERVICES
CHAIRMAN WARNED THE WHITE HOUSE
NOT TO ROB THE MILITARY'S
READINESS MONEY TO FUND THE
NATIONAL GUARD AT THE BORDER.
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH SENT A
6,000 TROOPS TO THE MEXICO
BORDER, IT COST $415 MILLION,
MONEY THAT WAS STRIPPED FROM THE
AIR FORCE AND NAVY'S OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE BUDGET.
THE PENTAGON JUST RECEIVED
$700 BILLION, A SIZABLE PORTION
OF THAT.
IT IS SUPPOSED TO HELP FIX